how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel that cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to the MCU and today we have
great news as it is official Mark
Ruffalo has signed on to reprise his
role as the Hulk now this comes as
little to no surprise as there's been a
lot of talk about Mark Ruffalo coming
back as the Hulk recently not to mention
there is a she-hulk
Disney plus series that'll be coming and
Jennifer Walters is the cousin of Bruce
Banner in the comics and in fact she
becomes she-hulk by getting a blood
transfusion from him so this means a lot
for the MCU especially when you consider
there have been very recent reports
about a Hulk vs. Wolverine film that
could possibly be coming to the MCU in
fact Mark Ruffalo himself has personally
said on several different occasions that
he would like to see that film take
place and as I'll explain in this
breakdown Mark Ruffalo is actually
signed on quite some time ago he's just
been very sly about it which is not like
him typically he is spoiling everything
like Tom Holland but we'll break down
everything that you need to know about
his return to what he's been saying
about a Hulk vs. Wolverine movie and the
Hulk's future in the MC you if you're
new be sure to subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all Marvel content and so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or ps4 now this
report today about Mark Ruffalo
returning as the Hulk has come from the
lumineer decom they have recently proved
themselves as a very reliable source
when it comes to MC related content way
before Christian Bale was officially
confirmed by Tessa Thompson to be
appearing in Thor love and thunder they
are the ones that originally broke the
news claiming that he was going to be an
otherworldly villain and this was indeed
confirmed a couple of days ago well now
they're back at it again confirming that
Mark Ruffalo has signed on to reprise
his role as the Hulk the report states
that a month ago when they broke the
report about some she-hulk
details they had heard rumors about Mark
Ruffalo signing up to be on the series
but they didn't get an official
confirmation so they didn't leak the
scoop however they now say that Mark
Ruffalo is signed sealed and delivered
for the she-hulk series coming to Disney
Plus the report says apparently Mark
Ruffalo has been playing coy and he's
already formally set and signed to
return to his iconic role
the she-hulk Show for Disney Plus
clearly our next question was what the
contract details were in regards to the
number of episodes and if this
negotiation was solely for the small
screen however we weren't able to get
that defined quite yet so Mark Ruffalo
is coming back as the Hulk for the
she-hulk series but is most likely
coming back for way more than that Red
Hulk is already confirmed to be coming
to the MCU relatively soon and it would
make perfect sense for Red Hulk to fight
the Hulk especially if you consider the
connection from The Incredible Hulk
which is canon to the MCU but let's talk
about the biggest thing that could be
coming to the MCU and that would be a
movie with the Hulk and Wolverine now
we've actually had quite a few different
reports on this and Mark Ruffalo himself
has even commented on it several times
as well now all the way back in November
at Tokyo Comic Con Mark Ruffalo made an
appearance and he talked about the
future of the Hulk in the MCU and what
he would like to see he also named
dropped Hulk vs. Wolverine and said that
he would like to see that happen in the
MCU and that he had a meeting with Kevin
Feige lined up where he was going to
pitch him ideas so in November at Tokyo
Comic Con he said Kevin Feige just asked
me last week if I had any more ideas or
stories for the Hulk and I said yeah I
think there's still some stories to tell
and he said well why don't you come in
and tell me about them and we'll see if
we can find a place for you in the
Marvel Universe and then Mark Ruffalo
said I'd like to see that Hulk vs.
Wolverine but then just a week ago Mark
Ruffalo brought this up again when he
was talking about the future of the Hulk
now at this point in time remember that
the Illuminati has said that he was
already signed up to play the Hulk in
the she-hulk series and at c2e2 he'd let
us know what he would like to see from
the Hulk at c2e2 a week ago he first
said that Universal does still have the
rights to the Hulk so they can't do a
solo hulk film however they can do a
solo hulk project if it's streaming or
on disney plus now clearly it's been
announced now that he's going to be on
the she-hulk series however he does go
on to say if he had his way for a Hulk
project this is how he would do it I'd
probably start him off kind of with him
on the run a little bit I think that
really works and in this new digital age
we're all
veiled that may be a kind of interesting
dimension of how he stays on the run
that's probably where we'd start him
saying I don't want to do this anymore
but it's hard now because he's the
professor he's hard to hide he went on
to say to be honest with you I want to
see a movie where Banner and the Hulk
battle it out and then the professor is
sort of a brainchild of that he said
Kevin Feige are you listening we want
professor Hulk the only person that the
Hulk is afraid of is banner and I want
to see the ultimate showdown between the
two of them and maybe Wolverine this
seems to be the ultimate goal for Mark
Ruffalo and the Hulk him taking on
Wolverine in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and for the first time in an
insanely long time this is an actual
possibility now that Disney owns the
rights to all of the x-men and we know
that Disney is thinking about a way to
introduce these major characters
Wolverine obviously being one of the
biggest ones and it could just be that
introducing Wolverine in a movie with
the Hulk could be the way to do it
Mark Ruffalo wants to do it and
according to a report from Mikey Sutton
months ago the studio's thinking about
doing it as well but Mark Ruffalo is
officially back in the MCU and hopefully
the path that his character goes down in
the MCU leads to Wolverine versus the
Hulk let me know how excited you are
that Mark Ruffalo is officially back in
the MCU as the Hulk and how excited
would you be if we got a Wolverine
versus the Hulk film in the MCU let me
know in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
when notifications turned on to stay up
to date on everything relating to the
MCU as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof